you're probably at least familiar with
the shotput it's a perennial favorite at
the olympics where the best shot putters
in the world make it look easy but it is
way more difficult than you might think
that thing weighs 16 pounds 16 pounds
right which is the
that's the mass of a bowling ball in
something the size of like a grapefruit
so you can't really throw it
instead you have to kind of shove it
from your shoulder or rather
put it
and most people just aren't strong or
coordinated enough to put a shot more
than a few feet but the pros
they can send a shot flying 50 60
70 feet or more
in 1990 american randy barnes set the
current world record of 23.12 meters
that's 75 feet 10 and a quarter inches
so what's keeping somebody else from
throwing even farther
today we're going to look at why putting
a shot more than 24 meters is almost
impossible
to find out what it takes i talked with
the olympic record holder
the spin generates more power but is
more unforgiving tried putting a shot
myself
you see you dropped your elbow here and
it spun out and spoke with a sports
technologist about what makes a perfect
put his looks something like this if we
went back to yours it would be something
like this now before we go any further
it's important to point out that that
23.12 meter world record
it needs a footnote just a few months
after he said it
american randy barnes was suspended from
competition after failing a drug test
his record however
still stands and a new generation of
athletes is coming closer and closer to
breaking it people are just
understanding the throw better that's
professional shot putter ryan krauser in
2016 he set the current olympic record
when he sent a shot flying 22.52 meters
nearly 74 feet i met up with him at the
u.s olympic training center in chula
vista california for a lesson you can
enter the ring to start your throw from
anywhere you'll see most people start
all the way at the back and after you've
completed your throw
you have to finish on balance and after
the implement lands then you can walk
out the back half
the rules of shot put are pretty
straightforward send this 16 pound ball
flying as far as you possibly can
without it landing out of bounds and
without setting foot outside the
throwing circle which measures seven
feet in diameter that's kind of the
great equalizer if it was bigger
taller guys like me would have a huge
advantage if it was smaller it'd be all
short guys my wrist's already tired is
that a bad thing yeah not a good sign
krauser's goal was to get me to throw 9
meters or about 30 feet
that's less than half the distance of
his typical throw
and keep in mind the distance is
measured from the inside of the toe
board to the point of first contact not
where it ends up rolling and the shots
right here coming he started by showing
me how to hold the shot ball is not in
the palm it's actually up on the
fingertips
right there
so you get that little snap so we'll
have you just start with the stick and
he had me do some standing throws the
most fundamental movement for shot so
left foot at the toe board
then right foot probably about right in
here shoulders to me
now squat down
and bring your center of gravity out
over your right foot all right
all right
you don't have to hide your
disappointment
that was better than than most people
but the
overall engine
is just not quite enough to power it
he's saying i'm small and weak
next he had me try the glide it's a
traditional shot putting technique that
involves scooting in a line across the
throwing circle from this position
you're sinking down and back in the
feeling of like a chair being pulled out
from under you so you're generating
energy
it's a it's three things this left foot
drive drive from the heel and then drive
across
well massive improvement little by
little and finally he had me try the
spin it's a rotational move and
krauser's preferred technique
with practice some athletes find it to
be more powerful than the glide but it's
also a lot more difficult to perform
consistently drive
man there you go so it goes
like that
kind of
okay and elbow up elbow up yeah
okay
you seem to be a glider
the goal of the glide as well as the
spin is to transfer as much energy as
possible from your lower body up through
your torso shoulder arm hand and finally
your fingertips right at the point of
release there's a ton of energy transfer
that happens right at the end we call it
the flick the last little bit of energy
transfer you store up all this energy in
a rubber band and at the end it's just
coming off just the fingers we actually
will end up taping the tips of my
fingers because they'll split there's so
much force on them it took everything i
had to heave this thing 30 feet and it
didn't even count on my spinning throw
because i fell out of the circle but
krauser can put shots twice that
distance and make it look effortless a
lot of that has to do with his
remarkable physicality the closest to us
would be like an offensive lineman or a
professional strong man krauser is six
feet seven inches tall weighs 315 pounds
and can fire off a 40 meter dash in
under 4.8 seconds he can also squat more
than 700 pounds and bench press 225
almost 50 times in a row
like many elite shot putters krauser
could probably play in the nfl if he
wanted to in fact he was actually
invited to try out for the indianapolis
colts but there's more to shot put than
brute strength krauser is also
surprisingly flexible and has
outstanding coordination at the 2019
world athletics championships in doha he
threw a personal best of
22.90 meters that's just 22 centimeters
shy of barnes record see that little
flick yep that adds even a little bit
more force to find out what makes
krauser's technique so effective i spoke
with john crosby he's a sports
technologist with the us olympic
committee talk to me about ryan
krauser's technique and his form and why
it's so fantastic yeah so i mean ryan's
just a beast as you can tell there's a
couple of different things that go that
are going on there ryan's just so in
tune with his appropriate perception
that he knows where his body is at all
times and he can really feel that
kinetic chain to see when he's coming
out of the back
that positional awareness allows krauser
to send the shot flying at close to the
perfect angle almost every time if
you're familiar with projectile motion
you know that the ideal launch angle for
distance is 45 degrees but for shotput
the optimum angle is actually quite a
bit smaller than that usually between 35
and 40 degrees and that's because
distance depends on more than just your
launch angle
it also depends on the speed at which
you put the shot or your release
velocity the problem is that in shot put
steeper launch angles lead to lower
release velocities and that's just
because humans are stronger in this
direction than they are in this
direction that's why most people can
bench press a lot more than they
overhead press plus moving a shot up
means having to fight gravity the point
being it's a lot easier to move a shot
horizontally than it is to move it
vertically which is why the sweet spot
is between 35 and 40 degrees shallow
enough to put some good speed on the
ball but still steep enough to get some
hang time how fast is it exiting your
hand and at what angle a great throw for
me is usually
between 36 and 40 degrees speed wise
you'll be looking about 32-33 miles an
hour and the forces required to produce
those speeds are tremendous remember how
krauser said he tapes his fingertips
well you and i would need way more than
tape to keep from injuring ourselves if
your hand
tried to
say
apply the pressure and need it for a 22
meter throw or 72 foot throw i think
every single tendon that connects all of
these would without a doubt be gone uh
and then you might some bones might
break as well so it would actually break
my hand trying to do what you're doing
but how much farther could someone
realistically put one of these things i
think with the levels that the athletes
are at and as the technique has
progressed i think that 24 would be
it'd be unbelievable to see
but it's not beyond the realm of reason
and what would that take in terms of
exit velocity the answer is less than
you might think relatively small changes
in release velocity can have a big
impact on total distance if you increase
the velocity by even a tenth of a meter
per second you add about 25 centimeters
to the distance of the throw here's
another way to put that
if krauser can find a way to add just
0.2 meters per second to his release
velocity that's less than 0.5 miles per
hour he could break the world record
another half mile per hour and he could
become the first person in history to
put a shot more than 24 meters now an
extra mile per hour on your release
velocity might not sound like much but
when you're already one of the best shot
putters in the world
it's enormous especially when reaching
for that last little ounce of
performance could mean risking serious
injury one of the biggest issues that
the shop players run into is just
staying healthy when you have that
amount of force like on your body that
often it's so easy to get injured and
then they're already towards the higher
end of strength levels and power levels
so for them to get even stronger you're
increasing that injury chance so what is
the ideal physiology for someone who's
capable of putting a shot more than 24
meters you want really really long
levers if you could make someone who's
six three with
say seven six arms because that just
lets you apply force for a longer time
uh and then super dynamic you'd have
someone who's fast in the sprints uh
really good at jumping and you just have
to have that baseline strength the
potential is there
it's just getting the individual that
can do it but until all those things
come together remember that what elite
athletes like krauser are doing today is
already almost impossible